[Musique]
pour être franc et être sincère sur une
vision bienveillante à l'égard de la
population de musiques noires installées
et qui vit depuis des décennies en
wallonie estime qu'il est évident de
leur conseiller de leur dire comme
directive d'europe d'opter pour rester
dans la france
eh bien bon jour michael et je suis très
contente de vous recevoir aujourd'hui
monsieur le sénateur nous connaissons
depuis quelques années oui j'ai eu le
bonheur le plaisir d'aller sur vos
terres à wallis aujourd'hui vous êtes
sénateur élu brillamment élu vous êtes
donc un sage est-ce que verser percevez
comme sa ferme et michael et bien je
n'aurai pas la prétention de dire ceci
comme ça mais pourquoi pas j'aimerais
bien le devenir en tout cas alors
sagesse c'était une douce provocation en
réalité parce que de sagesse il doit en
être bien question maintenant je vais
évoquer avec vous mika le problème de la
nouvelle calédonie alors pourquoi je le
fais je rappelle quelques chiffres la
nouvelle calédonie ses 290 1000
habitants environ la communauté
wallisienne est aujourd'hui à peu près
trente sept mille habitants c'est à dire
à peu près 13 % de la population de la
nouvelle calédonie vient des îles de
wallis et futuna
nous sommes aujourd'hui dans une
situation troisième de troisième
référendum qui se discute d'ailleurs en
ce moment puisque l'ensemble des des
responsables politiques loyalistes ou
indépendantistes ont été conviés par le
premier ministre la première question
qui me que je vais vous poser c'est
hélène réel impact sur le plan
démocratique de la communauté
wallisienne et futunienne sur le vote
dont en nouvelle calédonie je pense que
la population bolivienne et futunienne
musiciens instauré depuis des décennies
le wacken ligne représentent maintenant
trois ou quatre générations est donc
évidemment elle fait partie du corps
électoral taslé d'héliand savez chez
reed en studio on va droit au but
aujourd'hui au fond est-ce que la france
pourrait être remplacé par la chine qui
fait quand même les yeux doux la
population néo calédonienne est ce que
c'est un fantasme est-ce que ce que je
dis est purement fantasmatique
vous avez parfaitement raison d'évoquer
cette possibilité puisque la chine est
déjà présente dans la région
aujourd'hui sur le plan économique
puisque on s'occupe ici beaucoup
d'économies est-ce que l'herbe serait
plus verte avec un autre partenaire que
la france
on a vu par exemple les grandes
difficultés avec les usines de nickel au
plan économique il faut savoir que la
chine est toujours sous jacent derrière
l'horizon économique delannoy galloni
mine du nord est également la reprise de
la mine du sud il y a toujours pense
qu'il ya il faut pas négliger la
présence chinoise dans les négociations
j'ai envie de dire que sur un plan
philosophique il vaut peut-être mieux
poursuivre la discussion avec un pays
que l'on pratiqué depuis des décennies
avec la france oui de la france donc
depuis maintenant on va voir et de 111
ans plutôt que de s'aventurer
je dis bien s'aventurer avec un autre
pays étranger que l'on ne connaît pas et
dont nantes on soupçonne déjà les
pratiques une question très direct
chernick à monsieur le sénateur est ce
que vous appelez vous vous concitoyens
nos concitoyens wallisiens et futuniens
37000 qui vivent aujourd'hui en nouvelle
calédonie est-ce que clairement vous les
appeler à voter pour rester au sein de
la république pour être franc et être
sincère sur une vision bienveillante à
l'égard de la population de rustenhart
installés et qui vit depuis des
décennies en wallonie estime qu'il est
évident de leur conseiller de leur dire
comme directive d'europe d'opter pour
rester dans la france
même tout en sachant bien sûr certaines
subtilités et certaines évidences
concernant la légitimité du combat et
kanak en week-end et je veux rassurer le
peuple kanak dans ma prise de position
politique rapport asseoir et
coutumièrement en parlant je respecte
aussi leurs droits et leur légitimité
des kanaks en wec ennemis en tant que
premiers peuples tels izany vous venez
de faire une déclaration qui est
politique
très forte mon statut ne s'y retrouvent
pas facilitée parce que mon rôle est
très des nuances très compliqué
vis-à-vis de cette prise de position au
delà d'être aujourd'hui un homme
politique de premier plan
vous êtes aussi inscrit dans une
tradition très profonde
sauf erreur de ma part vous est de
descendance royale en tant que sénateur
gaulliste ou vivant à wallis et futuna
j'ai un devoir moral vis-à-vis de mes
compatriotes qui vivent en nouvelle
calédonie je n'ai juste qu'un conseil à
leur donner d'opter pour la sagesse
garde et l'accompagnement de l'état
français encore une fois je n'ai pas
envie de m'immiscer dans le la politique
calédonienne
néanmoins j'ai un devoir moral comme on
l'a dit tout à l'heure de venir en aide
et en soutien avec beaucoup de
bienveillance à l'égard de la population
au lycée fnac vie en nouvelle calédonie
cette continuité de destin commun comme
le conçoit vend dans lequel il faut voir
aujourd'hui ou demain l'avenir de
l'écurie
si la nouvelle annexe acceptent d'aller
à l'indépendance ou pas donc c'est à ce
moment là que je pose la question
quelles seront les garanties
je veux avoir quelque part des garanties
et c'est pour ça que je conseille à la
majeure partie de la population
bolivienne et futunienne de maintenir
cette cette option
eh bien merci beaucoup chernick à
monsieur le sénateur et à très bientôt
sur notre plateau des albums studio
merci beaucoup
[Musique]